you should always jump in and change and
if you're not then
shut the f because you don't have any
say
[Music]
what's up fun thank you for being on 20
minute leaders thanks for having me
this is so special this is the first 20
minute leaders out of i think 120
that i'm doing it in person anything
that we can
uh you know well mix it up is good well
i have the privilege of being here in
the hippo offices
and being a new hippo employee software
engineer here and
i've been waiting for a very long time
to do a video with you and so i'm very
happy to do it in person assaf
who are you wow uh every single person
that i meet in the valley in tel aviv
wherever they know a soft bond everybody
knows a self fund why is that
it's from the the pictures that i used
to have when i alone me and above
together actually no of course
i think it's a combination of two things
i think it's a combination
of me being for enough
time in this scene plus
uh basically the belief that
entrepreneurship is in a creative
environment and because of that you help
whenever you can
and you pass the back forward and you're
always being helpful
and the question that you should ask is
how can i help you
over a period of time
how long have you been an entrepreneur
how long do you consider yourself
is it from back from ibc zell from the
army
when do you consider yourself an
entrepreneur uh
i don't know i never consider myself in
depend oh i just consider myself i
cannot work for anybody i'm the worst
employee there is
okay so the only other option for me was
to build my own
uh environment right i'm just i'm not
very good with
uh iraqi i'm not very good in you know
in consulting i was a mediocre
consultant with mckinsey
i'm a lot better entrepreneur i think
i'm an
okay manager i think i'm set
up for you know i don't like status quo
any since i was a kid
it doesn't matter what i can go to the
ice cream parlor and i'm like what what
what in my mind is like that's the
dumbest thing ever because they should
pick up the money in here and do the
the the turnover there and then they
should they're always thinking about
how to improve and i'm not good at like
i i i believe that
uh you should always jump in and change
and if you're not then shut the [__] up
because you don't have any any say
right and because of that i'm basically
end up in
what is considered now with entrepreneur
you can call it self-employed in a
certain time
in between jobs whatever term you want
to call it i that's what i'm set up
interesting okay so hippo uh
entrepreneur you know a lot of people go
into cyber security
into a different b2c products a lot of
you know most of the things we see on tv
are b2c and these really fun products
that you're going to insurance
a really heavy industry very old
industry
and not something that the average
entrepreneur on the street would say huh
yes i'm ready to go into insurance yes
uh
what's up with that probably all of the
stuff that i believe
in entrepreneurship plus all of the
corrections for my prior
[__] ups are exactly in that field so
let me
uh let's break them into different
components let's do it
one it's a massive thumb it's a hundred
billion dollar just home insurance
itself
in the u.s so you know i'm not even
talking global and stuff like that in
the us
is a hundred billion dollar market that
grows at five billion dollars a year
so it's not this question of gartner is
saying that by 2027 this field is going
to be 2.3 billion dollars
and you have 17 different companies
vying for
bc money to basically go into that field
it's also a very interesting thing
because when you're pitching vcs it's
not about
and i'm going to be the most dominant in
keel state farm in allstate no
it does a lot of space for a lot of
other players in the market right give
us
one percent of this market we built a
five 10 billion dollar company so give
me a
let's go up 30 000 feet really quick and
then we'll come back down what is
insurance what is the home buyers
insurance
in the us over the past few decades what
are we seeing
because what we do at hippo here is is
something pretty unique
in the scope of of of insurance giving
yeah
so think about home insurance the last
100 years
channel is solely via agents you're
being sold
insurance via agent right the average
age of an agent now in the u.s is 60.
60 yeah the less than half the agent
that used to be 10 years ago
wow so now there's a bunch of when was
the last time but more people are buying
homes so how does that make sense
it's just that agents don't want to sell
you home insurance they want to shift
to sell your commercial product where
you don't have high frequency and you
sell
a lot more cars on the road yeah but do
you want to service people that have car
insurance because
every 1.7 years you have a claim because
someone nicked your car you had an
accident
and then you're calling your agent i
need a replacement card they fixed it
they didn't fix it there was a
depreciation and look
there's a point where you said effort
listen i i just want to do it i prefer
to sell you
something that doesn't have a high
frequency right and i make a lot more
money
so hence all auto insurance is shifted
to be direct
you're going to geico and progressive
you're buying vi call center of the
other web
our analysis was that there's going to
be similar lines
that are bound to go the route of direct
home insurance is one
smb is two and the third one is life
insurance
and we start to analyze all of these
things and we thought home insurance is
something that fits
our core skills of going deep into
specific areas a lot of data
and this is going to be tweaked so
firstly moving it to the direct
to enable it to purchase however you
want you can buy you know online mobile
via our call center that belongs to us
via other insurance company that sells
it we are independent
we're agnostic you're always going to
get the same price second thing
coverage is stuck in the 60s so if you
actually have the time when you're never
going to do it
and you're going to open your home
insurance policy you'll see that you'll
cover it for
stuff like fur coats five thousand
dollars uh
muslims and crypts six thousand dollars
yeah
uh i i don't know uh china
silverware copper whale things of that
gold bullion's
covered stamp collection two thousand
dollars
physical bonds that your granddad gave
you for you know a g
thing covered but electronics captured
two thousand dollars
well what you have in your bag now that
you have this fancy equipment it's even
more but
it's more than that uh home office not
covered right
bicycle camping equipment ski equipment
so basically the things that actually
are happening with the millennial
generation with the new yorkers
millennials like you know i'm not a
millennial in my and i have a lot more
electronics
in the home office and you know a lot of
other stuff that happens
there was some other stuff that when we
started the company was also
uh challenging lifestyle for us so for
instance gay couples
in states that we didn't recognize it
couldn't be registered
as both of them on the same policy
really
yes because it would the world recognize
this is married
so they're not ready i said so we live
together but only my half of the
of the closet is covered for losses but
not your half it was just
very foreign to us to how people live
their life
and and we thought that this is about
modernizing insurance
and doing right now so we started with
so we started the company five years ago
well the thought was we're going to
build
a direct or we're going to build guy
modernizing that's the second thing we
started with like we're going to build
progressive or geico for home insurance
that's how we started then we realized
the coverages are off so we need to
modernize home insurance and now we're
at a point
which is we
uh it's probably not the most branding
kind of thing because we haven't
massaged it enough but it's the shift
from being a reactive company
to proactive right insurance is a
reactive experience
you have a crappy onboarding at day one
we change that we we
you know we spend a lot of time you
you're very familiar with that right to
make it seamless pre-feed all of the
data for you
and then you have a crappy experience at
year 9 which we have a claim concert and
we're doing everything 24 7 and we have
an nps of like
70 on the claims when you have a on the
client on the claims
horrible situation you have an nps
because we need to be very honest with
our customers and help them as much of
our support
and what really drives me now is this
nine year time frame
that michael is a customer of people
until you have a claim yeah now think
about that time hey insurance companies
don't even call your customer they call
your policy order yes
because the customer was the agent not
the end customer
but the day that i onboarded hippo the
number of times that that
my onboarding and managers told me
michael we're we're looking at customers
not policy numbers get
just get that out of your head we're
we're customer forward we're going
forward
now we have multiple agents that sell us
are also customers and it's completely
fine and we need to build them tools
right to basically address them in the
right
way just like we need to focus back on
the customer so
think about that you have you bought a
policy yeah it was a shitty experience
fine you forgot about it
and then you know up front when you
bought the policy
that after nine years when you're going
to have a claim the first sentence
that's going to come up
of your mouth is i knew this [__] is
going to happen for nine years i've been
paying you guys every month
and just when it's going to happen i
knew is gonna happen like you know when
you
show me how many products in the world
like you're buying it
knowing it's gonna be like that when
it's gonna happen
more than that right it's a bizarre
product to begin with and we can have a
side discussion on that on
it's a product that you as a customer
don't ever want to use and me is the
person who actually
give you the product don't want you to
ever use it's a very awkward kind of
product really
okay so now we wanted what we decide is
like this
nine year time frame that you're a
customer
how can we align interest how can we
treat our customers differently
now you don't want to hear from us i'm
your insurance company me
sending you weekly like what the hell am
i just going to block me
on the spam and we haven't done anything
so there needs to be something
deep in alignment right and insurance
now is a reactive uh process
you you you're paying every year on the
renewal and then after nine years you
have a claim
and now the insurance companies you know
that's the the time
to deliver on that and it's usually it
doesn't work well of course so we
thought about that what's the best
experience
in the world for a claim is that you had
the claim and five seconds later someone
stepped in
you had the damage on your wolf there
was a leak in the roof
and it's twenty thousand dollars you
need to replace the roof and five
seconds later someone came
michael ears your twenty thousand dollar
check which is exactly the sum
and this is as good as it can be but
then for three weeks you're not gonna be
at home
you need to find a contractor to fix
your roof you probably lost some of the
artifacts that you have in the in the
stuff
all of your favorite clothes your
favorite sofa
and it's a mess and this is as good as
it could be that someone
gave you you would my insurance company
was amazing i had the damage and they
paid
everything on the spot that's a crappy
experience so we thought
what can be better than that and we
thought that the best experience
is if we avoid the claim from happening
in the first place which is good for us
as an insurance company but it's very
good for you
yes so this is was a shift to be
proactive insurance company and it has
three components
one we basically said why do we use the
data only once if i'm already
pre-filling all of the data aerial
imagery to see the condition of the roof
permit records and all of that why are
we doing it only once for the onboarding
shouldn't we do underwriting on an
ongoing basis right so every time i have
an aerial imagery pool
we're running all of our customers
basically homes
through that and if there is a
discoloration on the roof on michael's
home
someone is going to call you and say
listen our data's you know you know that
we're monitoring your home from time to
time
our data sources showed that you had uh
you know a discoloration on the roof i
think we should send it will fail
and it's going to be free of charge and
you know i mean that's part of the
modernization where you're not you're
not relying just on on them filling out
a 15-minute questionnaire of
when was the what year was your roof
built nobody knows exactly
you go and you automatically you're able
to pull in all these sources and it's
not just passively
pulling them you're actually actively
looking and developing technologies
because they're able to look at pictures
look at aerial maps
consolidate with different apis and then
real perform
a high analysis ongoing and then let's
do it on going
to help prevention from happening in the
first place i'll give you an example
like
uh i think like 14 of our customers
have something material changing their
house when it comes to renewal and i
mean
out of the swimming pool uh turn the
garage into a living room
right you know do a free full review of
the kitchen and and stuff like that
broke a wall i'm not a single one called
us
now i don't blame them because it's not
like uh why do now when we're calling
and say listen mike we saw that you
added a swimming pool
yeah and by the way uh you know i i
think i think we should increase your
liability insurance because there's a
chance that the
the kid's neighbor is going to jump into
the pool when you're away
yeah and it's risky i think we should
increase it and it's going to cost you
an extra 2.30
in 99.9 percent of them say oh thank you
so much i really really forgot about
that
now sometimes it's the other way around
sometimes uh uh we saw that the permits
record showed that
you replaced the roof and you were
entitled to a five percent discount it's
not about maximizing and upselling it's
about making sure
that this contract that we have of an
insurance company and they insured
is that we're going to be the safety net
and instead of the safety net getting
smaller and smaller and have gaping
holes
we're constantly making sure that it's
the right kind of safety in it
to catch you if god forbid something
happen and this is what we're doing so
one is
using the data to do ongoing underlining
second thing
is we give packages uh iot device
we actually in this room you can
probably bring from the other side of
the table oh yeah yes
this is one of the most one of the
things that excites me most about what
we're doing here
so this we have we have several formats
this is every customer of epo is getting
that
let's open that let's see what this is
kangaroo this is the kangaroo
it has a software it has a bunch of
stuff
it has a motion sensor smoke detector
fire alarms and what happens what
happens when the person gets it
first they smile and then they just plug
it in they install it what
what happens then so a they get a
discount they get a smart home discount
for the product b these are
self-monitored kits
this is not it was monitoring these
these things we have two smart
smartphone kind of strategy right we
have something which is the basic one
which is self monitor which is this one
and then we have professional monitoring
where you're also paying i don't know 15
to 30
a month and you get a full monitoring or
you know
and then it's not it doesn't come to us
it comes to the
you know the police and stuff like that
but we only get if it's on or off
but it's it's self money so it's not me
being big brother and monitoring that
and capping it's not about that it's
about
alerting you that you have a water leak
in your basement
and oh now i'm going to go and check it
out
as opposed to the water leaking for
three days and then i'm coming to the
basement and it's completely full so
it's about these things so one is uh
using the data ongoing
second one is smart home and
every customer is basically unless they
opt out get that
right and the third thing are people are
people open to
to doing that we have like uh
i think 75 to 80 installation rates
which is crazy that's insane
which is crazy because 10 12 are opting
out
so you they're like eight percent are
like you know
i think when i see a win-win situation
you're sending them these devices pre
that
hippo is sponsoring and then you tell
him listen we're not going to make money
off of this let's form a win-win you're
going to plug these in you get a
discount on your quote
yes and you're not going to lose your
house you're not going to lose your
belongings because
none of us want that exactly you don't
want to lose your belongings we don't
want to file a claim
so let's come up with the win-win
situation where we avoid it in the first
place
it's on us and you get to you get a chat
was exactly the strategy of this
that that is so cool and is that is that
proving itself so now
you're seeing it over you know ah dozens
of thousands of homes
moving itself we need more time to have
a statistically significant like uh you
need
at least 9 years but it's also it
doesn't statistically significant
we know that for me everything in
insurance needs to make a claim so for
me to say that
if reduced by four percent i need to
have over a silver
and eight hundred percent but it's
definite but intuitively as a ceo yes
thank you so much for this we had a leak
in this
and we stopped it or we had a problem
you know
we woke up in the middle of the night
because there was a fire alarm and then
we realized there was a fire
and it was another room and you know
stuff like that
so even sporadically even if i have a
hundred
water claims and i stopped one in a
hundred it's better than not having it i
mean plus the sense of
trust and stuff like that the last thing
which is also interesting for that
i think it helps build a brand yeah in a
way so the thing is
if you want to build a brand in general
you need to bring consistent benefit to
a customer
insurance companies when i ask you or
are you you're auto insured with i don't
know all state state farm maybe farmers
i don't know it's almost
like i don't even remember because
nobody because you don't have any touch
point with them i can call them
that's it and that's it and then it
stays and maybe if you have a claim
you'll remember that i go on my gmail
and i look up the insurance card and i
look and then
then you know okay yes now i need to
autocall so think about that
that in order for us to build the brand
we need to bring value to the customer
on an ongoing basis right
this send you the door is locked the
door is unlocked there was a water leak
there's not a water leak
you build an affinity and it's a good
positive kind of thing
which is why what's a hippopotamus right
outside
right outside of this room we have a
huge hippopotamus staring at us yes uh
there are two answers so the answer is i
want the real one you know
the answer i usually get i'll give you
the the right one is not
sexy i don't want to not really usually
the answer is that i'm giving is that
everything with the word uh mutual and
state and farm was taken
so we had to come up with something
different but the the real answer
is in the world so in the world of
brands today
there's no more brands there's no try
and find a name for a company
that you get the the domain you get the
twitter handle
you get the facebook thing you don't
have 15 typos and it ends with uh
co you know it's just not something that
happens
so you're trying to find and then you go
you want to go that and you start
in this room listen let's look at
animals let's look at flowers let's look
at greek gods
let's look at yours places let's look at
monuments
let's look in and you and you're
realizing really really fast
there's no more names so then at the end
of the day you find something that
you know you don't really get the domain
but the domain is somewhat available you
get
you know you're kind of making something
you said you know what and it's not
associated and you go for it
and in our case it was hippo well if you
would have asked me
five years ago i would have told you
there's probably 80 chance we're going
to change
it's a placeholder amazing that was like
let's say yeah listen
we like it but it's probably going to
pop up as a problem or something like
that and we would probably need to do a
redo
of the brand and stuff like that and
with time we actually liked it more and
more
and and it's awesome now there's also
another thing there's a lot of
i read too many books on that but if i
summarize them into one kind of sentence
is the earlier
the person who can grasp your brand the
better the brand is
and unless it's associated so apple has
no association with electronics and what
it is
sure but a two-year-old can grasp the
name freaking awesome uh
so you're trying to find something
similar so you're trying to find
something but google is probably an
eight-year-old can grasp
not a three or four the name google yeah
like even though it's like it's not
it's not trivial it's not it's not a
concept it's like you know yeah it's
it's something there's something behind
it but you know it used to be a time
like you know progressive
yeah it's like yeah so yeah so you're
trying to find something
and not that everybody likes their
insurance company so you try to find
something non-associated with insurance
which is memorable
it's kind of like you know there is the
elevator kind of test
on telling a story this is like it's an
elevator test on
remembering the brand when someone
leaves the elevator or not
yeah what's the name of the company
what's the chances of me telling and
listen we're an insurance company called
hippo just that 100
and then three days later like what was
the name yes
there's a way higher likelihood and that
was basically the thought behind it not
that uh
of course we have uh ippo stands for
home insurance policy
of course bullshitness i can't believe
we already have to go in a minute but i
have to get your i have to get
your point of view you're in a hyper
growth state a
company is doing very very well already
unicorn and
lots and lots of employees how many
employees are we now in the company 270.
270 employees did you did you think when
you sold your last business that you're
going to be running
are you kidding me this is like 207 you
wake up
you have to lead 270 people and it's
growing so every week
i'm getting new emails welcome blah blah
blah welcome blah blah blah
how like how do you approach this state
of mind have you done this before
experiencing this growth far for no not
ever
uh but that's the reason why we're not
selling and we're excited to come every
day
yeah the growth mindset and how much
i personally learn and the rest of the
team is learning by
evolving and moving to the next step
every day it's a new day it's a new
learning
it's it's it's a different it's a
different company
i always ask myself am i the right
person to lead the company am i the best
ceo for the company
can someone else be better uh what do i
need to personally learn
to be better or if i have gaps who
should i bring
into do you feel the same intimacy with
the branding with
you know this desk and these walls as
the days goes
go by and you you disassociate more and
more with the everyday things
because you must be different different
it's part of the growth or it's probably
the hardest thing for me
on my growth journey was to let go of
stuff i used to know every freaking
thing
every every process every contract
everything and there's a certain point
that
hey you can't because the entire
management basically experience is about
leverage
finding someone else that can leverage
you doing it and the second thing
you find people that are way stronger
than you and what they're doing you know
ronnie is a way better
technologist than what i am in in order
to attract the right talent you need to
let go and let them run their own stuff
and not intervene
and trust them to brief me on the stuff
that i need to be briefed so
on the on one side i'm not in the you
know in the minutia on the other stuff
i'm exposed to a lot other kind of
things which
i find really really interesting that's
part of the evolution and the growth
and i'm constantly like what's the next
steps how can i evolve
the data i'll feel that uh you know i've
i haven't gone enough to accommodate the
business oh that i've
you know i've hit my mark that would be
a different discussion
do you feel that you'll be able to have
that discussion with yourself yeah yeah
i've known really
i have no egos with when it comes to the
company on these things even though it's
your baby and you grew it from day one
i yeah no it's not it's it's it's not
about you know i never uh
it's not that since i was four year old
i wanted to be a ceo of a public
insurance company or something like that
it's not
that's not the driving force for me
it's about you know education
growth uh doing good making an impact
learning every day because i think
entrepreneurship is [__] it's hard it's
difficult
but there are several things that are
that you can control you can control the
domain that you're working in
and what you're working on the people
that you work with and
the culture and this is the biggest
thing and as long as you have you're
working on something that is interesting
and so exciting
people that you like and i can still
influence the culture and i like the
culture of the
gonna keep on doing company i love it
three words that best describe you
how would you describe yourself in three
words this is something that i ask
every person on the show and it's now
fascinating to see it come together
uh so it's not it's not bored so uh you
know independent thank you
uh i believe in uh strong opinions
loosely held
strong opinions loosely held so i think
that when you come into a discussion you
should have an opinion
okay but you should you should defend it
and you should be thoughtful
but you should be open that if someone
comes up with data and
stuff like that that you're like okay
yeah i can see that and you're loosely
held
on so the second part is just as
important as the first part yes
uh which is you know part of the other
stuff is we have obligation to dissent
and all of that
stuff is part of the culture uh
and then i think that uh
being a mensch an honest and good friend
and all of that is something that is
really really important
is it for the company for the culture
and for me personally i love it
stuff thank you very very much no i'm i
can be
you know happier than having you on
board it's like fantastic bring us a lot
more michaels
no this is fantastic and and i have to
say that walking in here the culture
it it perceives itself and yeah the
business is great and the technology is
fantastic and
and and i love the people around me the
culture and the feeling that
of what you've built here over the 207
employees and i can't wait to see you
grow
and continue to grow and i'm excited to
be part of the journey thanks so much
thanks so much for that
[Music]